hey I'm Tiffany Haddish and I'm doing it
puppy interview for BuzzFeed G ready you
gonna just have the puppies at the
beginning alright let's go what up dog
hey I like the pits let's keep these
party started hey puppy alright so
considering your difficult pass what
advice would you give to young kids who
have big dreams but feel stuck I would
say move forward figure out what it is
that you love to do stay focused stay
focused stay focused do one thing every
day towards your goal and get there you
will get you no matter how bad something
is right now that means it's fun good on
the other side of that bag like if a
puppy take a poop right now I know that
somebody in here got a plastic bag
forget that poop up and get it out of
here see how they go what's your
favorite quality about yourself and
what's one thing you're insecure about I
would say one of my favorite qualities
about me is my boobie I like my butt and
one of the things I'm insecure about is
my eyebrows which shows are you
currently obsessed with right now I'm
currently obsessed with reruns of Shira
and he-man
I like the Smurfs also I like watching
I like watching Empire and yes I'm
obsessed with reruns of pound puppies
okay
what movie genre would you do outside of
comedy and why what's Rama gangster
movies you know I'm doing a romantic
comedy right now I'll do a romantic
drama love stories I would like to do
document documenting type of movies like
we're not documenting movies
what's the what you call that when you
do somebody life story life story movies
alright build a playlist
songs for when you you're feeling sad I
like to play upbeat music to change that
emotion so you know some like Sierra
some Beyonce some James Brown you know I
played that kind of music when I'm
filling the bag cuz then that raises up
my vibration I don't like to be sad when
I'm ready to party I play some Beyonce's
I'm Sierra this new dog some you know to
lifeproof yeah and thinking of BAE when
I'm thinking of a dude I like the plays
from Erica if I do some Maxwell some
some Marvin Gaye something yes you're
good doggy
fine I don't have no snacks if I have
next Hey I don't kiss I don't kiss
everybody in the mouth you used to work
as an energy producer what but what puts
you in a really good mood things that
put me in a really good mood my thoughts
I'm coming up a [ __ ] lab okay
who was your favorite actor slash
actress to work with so far and who was
the most difficult to work with my most
favorite actor/actress to work with thus
far is the cats from Keanu movie I was
in with Jordan Peele
the cat her name is Clementine she now
lives with me she's amazing to work with
and to live with and the worst to work
with was a baby that was in it scene I
don't remember that baby name I just
know that baby was not a good baby if
you had a superpower what would be your
kryptonite cheese I can't stand cheese I
mean because by something some kind of
cheeses I like but then
all of them mess my stomach up but
sometimes I'm necessary anyways just to
humble myself
what's one skill you wish you possessed
or wish you were better at I wish I
possess the skill of talking to animals
I can talk to them but I'm not good at
it see I wish I was better anywhere I
get them to talk back we working on me
what do you think would be your job if
you weren't an actress or comedian I
would be a sex education teacher because
I think that is very important to teach
people had to have proper sex okay Jilla
okay I heard you were fluent in Japanese
is that true Hey nihongo got suppose she
want cutting mascot tell us your worst
first date story we don't got time for
that but we'll just say this
a man's car stank right into this day I
don't let me and pick me up for dates
I need them there because I did not want
all show that happened to try to hump me
that happens who they try to hump me for
no I was like Hello we and Chili's why
are you trying to hump me in the chili
stop it
who is your celebrity crush and what
would you do if you met them I have met
my celebrity crush in there are several
and when I met them I ask them on a date
ask them if I could cook for them after
the [ __ ] of rub on their bodies they all
turn me down
Trevor no one I could be joined one more
question
this is the last one guys come on in
bring it in bring it in
okay stay there you get it back what was
the what was the last coupon you
purchased an adult toy because I broke
the last month
I'm not really dating right now we have
to do what we have to do I like to call
it safe sex and nobody does it like me
make sure you go see nobody's fool in
theaters November the second okay and
just in case you were wondering all
these puppies are adoptable from North
Shore Animal League check them out North
Shore Emily they have really great
puppies shoot you might find a man there
you know what I'm gonna go visit North
Shore Animal League and see who worked
it may be my future man is deep who
knows
do y'all hire single dudes okay
looks like I'm going to north store
animal need to find me a real dog
[Music]
you